So we said that in a partial directory we
can run out of directory entries. So if we
need to allocate a new entry because a block
is being sent to a level one and level two
cache and we need to mark where it's present
the question is, what do we do in our
directory. And the answer is we pick an entry
to replace, for example, using some sort of LRU algorithm
in our directory. Let's call that entry E. So, that
E is the entry we are replacing, not the new
entry we are putting in. The new entry we put
in, we know what to do with it. We are going to
set that one presence bit to one. The question is
what do we do about the entry E because that
entry might have some presence bit set. For every presence
bit that is set in that entry that we are replacing
we need to send an invalidation to the
corresponding cache. Pretty much this entry says that that
block is in some caches. We're going to
tell these caches to either invalidate or send us
the data and invalidate, so that at the
end of this process all of the presence bit
can be set to zero at which point, entry E can be removed from the cache because
all presence bits are zero and such an entry does not need to be kept in the
cache. And now we can put a new entry
there. So note that now we are not invalidating
blocks because of coherence. We are invalidating them
because of limited capacity in our directory. So this
technically would be yet another type of miss that
we can have. It's a miss that had nothing
to do with either coherence or capacity or
conflict or anything like that. It's a type of
miss that usually we don't need to name, but
just be aware that it exists. So we can
have a cache miss in a level one or
level two cache that was caused by an invalidation,
and that invalidation was not due to coherence, was
not due to a write. It was due to
a replacement of that block's directory entry on the chip.